bueno en el vídeo anterior les dije que
si conocíamos el cambio en distancia y
conocíamos la aceleración y la velocidad
final entonces la pregunta fue cómo
podíamos encontrar la velocidad final
entonces nuestros datos
eran la el cambio en distancia
la aceleración
y la velocidad inicial
bueno si no recuerdan les recomiendo que
regresen a ver el vídeo anterior
entonces encontramos la siguiente
fórmula que es la velocidad final al
cuadrado es igual a la velocidad inicial
al cuadrado más 2 veces el cambio en la
distancia
y recordamos que este término lo podemos
encontrar como distancia cuando asumimos
que la distancia inicial es cero así que
la diferencia en distancia resulta igual
a la distancia final pero podemos
usarlas ilícitamente yo espero que estas
alturas se den cuenta de por qué sigo
cambiando entre términos distancia y
diferencia de distancia pues es para que
ustedes se familiaricen con ambos
términos esta es la fórmula para cuando
no no sabemos cuál es la velocidad final
pero ahora vamos a calcular el tiempo
si tenemos que no sabemos el tiempo
y encontramos la velocidad final podemos
encontrar el tiempo más adelante vamos a
ver cómo lo hacemos pero ahora vamos a
ver cómo encontrar el tiempo cuando nos
dan con los datos
la diferencia en distancia
la aceleración y la velocidad inicial
entonces tenemos nuestra fórmula
diferencia en distancia
/ la diferencia
la diferencia
del tiempo es igual a la velocidad
promedio
y esto también lo podemos expresar como
la ave los la diferencia en distancia es
igual
a la velocidad promedio por la
diferencia en el tiempo
esto recordando nuevamente si tenemos la
distancia inicial igual a cero y el
tiempo inicial igual a cero eso lo
podemos escribir como distancia igual a
la velocidad promedio por el tiempo pero
detrás nos vamos a seguir trabajando con
esta fórmula de las diferencias de
distancia
entonces tenemos nuestros datos
diferencia distancia aceleración
velocidad inicial y queremos conocer el
tiempo
y bueno como calculamos nuestra
velocidad promedio sustituyendo en esta
forma para hacerlo más simple sabemos
que nuestra velocidad promedio es la
velocidad final más la velocidad inicial
entre 2
y esto lo multiplicamos por el tiempo es
importante recordar que esta velocidad
promedio sólo podemos usarla cuando
tenemos una aceleración constante y en
el caso del problema como estamos
trabajando con la gravedad que es es una
aceleración constante podemos usar este
dato de velocidad promedio no para usar
esta fórmula directamente porque no
conocemos cuál es la velocidad final
entonces vamos a tratar de calcular la
velocidad final en término de los otros
datos que sí conocemos y entonces bueno
tratar de encontrar el tiempo que
sabemos de la velocidad final bueno
sabemos que la velocidad final bueno
tenemos pues bien que la diferencia en
velocidad
es igual a la aceleración por el tiempo
y de aquí tenemos que esta diferencia de
velocidad la calculamos como velocidad
final menos velocidad inicial que es
igual a la aceleración por el tiempo
vamos a despejar nuestra velocidad final
y dejarla igual que es a la velocidad
inicial
más la aceleración por el tiempo y vamos
a usar esta fórmula a sustituir la
dentro de esta otra entonces tenemos
distancia
es igual
y nuestra velocidad inicial
más vamos a sustituir la velocidad final
y vamos a usar otro color para que se
noten nuestra velocidad final que viene
siendo aquí velocidad inicial más la
aceleración por el tiempo
realizamos a nuestro color inicial más o
menos
entre 2
multiplicado por el tiempo
y multiplique si usamos este
multiplicamos el tiempo por los términos
de esta ecuación y aquí vemos que ve y
más bien pues es igual a 2 b
vamos a ver
dos veces la velocidad de inicial más la
aceleración por el tiempo entre 2
multiplicado por el tiempo estos dos se
cancelan y vamos a multiplicar el tiempo
por estos dos términos y nos queda que
la velocidad inicial por el tiempo
más
la aceleración por el tiempo al cuadrado
entre 2 y esta es nuestra diferencia en
el tiempo de para nuestra diferencia en
la distancia
igual a la velocidad inicial por el
tiempo
más la aceleración por el tiempo al
cuadrado entre 2
y bueno con esto vamos a tomar
este momento para hacer un resumen ya
que ahora tenemos todas las fórmulas que
podríamos necesitar para resolver
problemas de movimientos de proyectiles
de una dimensión
recuerden que esto no sirve para cosas
que se mueven ya sea de este-oeste de
izquierda a derecha de arriba hacia
abajo y no en ambas eso lo vamos a ver
en el siguiente vídeo así que vamos a
hacer un resumen de las fórmulas que
conocemos hasta el momento
entonces hagamos nos quiere sumen
tenemos que la diferencia
en distancia
/ la diferencia
el tiempo es igual a la velocidad
promedio
recordando que usamos velocidad promedio
cuando tenemos una aceleración constante
y tenemos que la diferencia en velocidad
entre la diferencia en el tiempo va a
ser igual a la aceleración
nuestra velocidad promedio la vamos a
calcular usando la velocidad final más
la velocidad inicial
entre 2
esto recordemos cuando usamos la
aceleración
constantes
y en el tercer vídeo calculamos o
encontramos que la velocidad final al
cuadrado era igual a la velocidad
inicial al cuadrado más dos veces la
aceleración por la diferencia en la
distancia y encontramos que la distancia
es igual a la velocidad inicial por el
tiempo más la aceleración por el tiempo
al cuadrado entre 2
continuaremos resolviendo el problema
que estaremos viendo en el siguiente
vídeo